folks how we doing today we're going to
give you a bit of a pallet fork guide so
how to select the right set of pallet
forks for your tractor you know little
subcompacts a compact a large frame
utility a skid steer whatever it is
different options different quick attach
types fork tine lengths weight
capacities all that good stuff so stick
around
john deere quickitch just has two of
these pins one on each side down in the
corners sometimes they don't have much
weight or when they're brand new they
have a little bit of extra paint build
up they might not seep the whole way
through
or only just a swift kick
we'll seated on there
and once you take a bucket or forks or a
push or anything on and off you're gonna
wear all the paint off around here those
tolerances are pretty tight so um once
you wear it in it's normally not an
issue at all okay so now we're gonna put
the tines on the frame itself and you'll
notice along the bottom rail a small
little cutout and that's to allow you to
actually get the tine onto the frame and
then you're going to slide it to the
left or to the right okay i'm going to
give this a shot see if i can actually
use the tractor lower it down to the
right angle and
pick right up underneath here so i don't
have to lift it up of course i could
these are the ultralight forks so
they're not all that heavy but if you do
have a larger set like a standard duty
or one of the 4 200 500 pound sets
well those are really heavy tines so
anyway let's see if this works
[Music]
all right so i just missed that center
slot but you can see the top rails on
here so right now it's not fully seated
i'm going to give it a quick shift
and now it's on we do have our pin
that's in the unlocked position so
that's going to allow it to slide
all the way over we'll just
go wherever we want right about here and
you can kind of
shift it around and you're going to have
a little bit of wiggle room all right a
little bit of wiggle room is going to be
typical for all these this is steel on
steel so you have to have some place so
that you can freely slide it otherwise
you would bind them up all the time
you'd never move them you just hate
using them so this is just fine to have
a little play
all right so it's as easy as that
you're going to have a quick attach for
the john deere or the skid steer
depending on your tractor setup we'll
get more on that later but we're going
to line them up now let you see them all
side by side and give you that
comparison all right so we got them all
lined up in no particular order i got
the hydraulic forks these are 5 500
pound
frames skid steer quick attach you know
you need a hydraulic connection
ultra light these are the really popular
ones for the subcompacts these are john
deere quick attach
two thousand pound forks there on the
big kubota and then we have our 4 200
pound with a full brick guard forks on
the 20 25. now i got to point out those
forks are too big for that 20 25 all
right that normally goes on my 4720 that
i have and previously the 4066r but i
don't have that tractor out here right
now so
it's just holding fork so you can see
what they are and you're going to notice
these hydraulics aren't hooked up right
now i'm having a heck of a 24 hour
period right now i um well i'll show you
the back of my enclosed trailer i
smashed in
the top of that that was fantastic i
forgot to put a roll bar down so
feeling pretty good about that
then we have a drone that's about 50
foot up in the trees that we got stuck
there earlier today
and
the heat has expanded the fluid inside
of the hydraulics here and we can't get
the quick
couplers on the hydraulics to show you
how these will go in and out
hydraulically so this is the second time
this has happened to me this spring
there's just too much pressure in this
side when these sit out in the sun it
starts to warm up everything expands in
here there's just too much pressure
build up and you can bleed these off but
that's just you know
that's just annoying what i need to do
is stop procrastinating and get my hec
the hose end chambers hooked up on here
that's exactly what they're for is to
put on here when you're not using them
when they're going to be sitting outside
having the heat hit them have them warm
up and swell that fluid can expand into
the chamber and then go back right into
it if it's going to cool down it can
easily come off you need to hook it up
it prevents these problems from
happening because i really had to use
these right now i would be
up a creek basically so
check out the hose end chamber they're
relatively inexpensive you can save five
percent using code gwt so
anyway we're going to keep playing with
this see if we can get that hooked up i
do have a set of fork extensions that
are super handy as well i'm going to
show you what those are later on they
can go on pretty much any forks that are
out here but they'll extend out if you
need something really lightweight but
just a really long reach you get like a
six foot extension on those they're
pretty cool so let's start with weight
classes on all these and identify what
those are so we're gonna have 900 pound
on these guys 2 000 pound on the kubota
4 200 way over there on the end and then
5500 now that pound rating is going to
be at a load center or a load point that
um the little guys here is 21 inches out
from the frame so if you measured 21
inches out this way that's where that
900 pound capacity comes into play on
all the bigger ones i believe it's going
to be 24 inches a little bit further out
because
more often you're going to be at 48 or
60 inch tines on those and all these
forks are are overbuilt all right i
think it was like three years ago i put
a set of these little guys on my 4066
that i had back in the day
and lifted up a huge stack of weight
well over 2 000 pounds of them these
things i i used them for like a month on
that tractor they held up just fine so
you guys that ask questions like on your
two series tractors like that 2025r or
the 2032 2038 your kubota
lx 3310 all that those kind of tractors
that are really just one step above a
subcompact they're gonna work really
well on there so why i recommend these
lightweight these little guys for those
tractors like the subcompacts and the
next size up is because of the physical
weight of the entire assembly this is
going to weigh about 190 200 pounds
right in that ballpark
the next step up is the standard duty
forks those weigh 130 pounds more than
what these guys lift so that's 130
pounds of just lifting up the forks that
your loader has to do that's taking away
from whatever you want to put on the
forks whatever you want to put on a
pallet or a log or something else that
you want to lift so that's a lot of
weight that's eaten up for a little
loader like this so really weight is a
concern on smaller tractors with limited
capacity once you have a significant
loader capacity weight's really not a
concern with the forks you're more
concerned about making sure the frame is
built rugged and robust and not going to
fail on you and so on that note you're
going to see that all these forks are
hla forks which is up in ontario i've
been selling their equipment for a long
time their snow pushers are super
popular you guys watching if you own hla
products i know a lot of you do leave a
comment down below and let those other
folks watching know just how high
quality these products are one big
decision you need to make is if you need
a jdqa or an ssqa all right john deere
quick attach for john deere's skid steer
quick attach for kubota's for mahindra's
for coyotes for ls for new holland
pretty much everything else that's out
there but that's not always standard
sometimes you do have a pinned on bucket
or a goofy type of quick attach and we
can order forks to fit those kinds of
setups but they are typically going to
be an up charge because it's kind of a
custom job for hla to do and typically
going to be a longer lead time as well
all right something else we should
discuss before we go any further is
safety all right so that's ballast
weight so let's have chris back up just
a touch tell you more about it so we
spend a lot of time talking about safety
on this channel and it's because we have
a lot of new tractor owners joining the
group all the time so it's worth
mentioning again that you want to have a
lot of counterweight on the backside of
your tractor anytime you're using that
front end loader here you see we have
what's called our hitch hanger so if you
have a quick hitch like the spiko you
can put these weight brackets on the
side
still leave your three-point hitch open
to hook up an attachment if you want to
or if you need additional ballast weight
besides say the versa bracket and
suitcase weights or a ballast box or
another attachment so between these six
weights and the hitch hangers you can
get up to another 450 pounds of ballast
weight if you need it as always we're
sponsored by borah wheel spacers they
are made in america have a lifetime
warranty if your tractor feels tippy
side to side especially if you have a
cab on it then adding a set of wheel
spacers can make a big difference get
more information on them at the link
down below okay so you may think pallet
forks are only good for picking up
pallets but i wrote down all sorts of
stuff here and if i missed something
make sure you let us know but pallet
forks are great for
moving logs brush piles stacks of
anything you have patio furniture used
as a hanging mechanism for butchering
deer or seeing under a mower deck moving
hay bales supporting posts if you're
trying to put posts on the ground or you
know fence posts or a flagpole
hauling posts if you need to move them
around large boulders truck caps taking
them off of the back of your truck
moving heavy appliances the list just
goes on and on there's all sorts of uses
anytime you want to have a couple of
long fingers out there to grab something
you can use a set of pallet forks so
another decision you have to make is
going to be the right time length for
you all right and so
i think there's too many choices out
there personally it's just a lot of
inventory to carry you know these six
inch increments don't make a whole lot
of difference i i sometimes feel like i
just need to carry one size for each
frame and call it good but we have 42
inch forks on the little guys right now
you can get 36 42's 48s i don't carry
the 48s at all i probably just need to
carry 36 or 42.
you don't want the extra length the
further out you go with any forks the
less lift capacity you have so you do
want to keep things closer to the
tractor i wouldn't lose sleep over 36 or
42. now you had the same choices 36 42
48 on the 2000 pound frame
i typically don't stock the 36s on here
either the 42s or the 48s once you get
up to the 4200 pound and the 5500 pound
and so on it's pretty much 48 54 60 and
you can even get into 72 inch tines okay
so again typically you want to always
keep your load as close to the frame and
the in the base of the of the forks as
possible the further out you go the less
weight you can lift also if you have
longer times those are going to of
course way more than shorter times too
so there's that consideration as well a
bigger concern for smaller tractors and
larger ones but if you're tight on
storage space and of course a shorter
fork may work to your advantage so
you'll notice there's a different look
to these forks
probably more from your angle than from
mine so the shortest back is going to be
on the light guys here and so of course
you're saving weight by not having a big
tall back it doesn't mean there's no
back right you can still see you have a
good what 18 20 inches something like
that
right here to kind of back again so it'd
be really challenging for something to
fall back over this way i've never had
that issue at all now once you get up to
the 2000 pound forks you're going to see
there's an even taller back so again
those lighter duty ones come up to about
right here you have an extra i don't
know 10 12 inches something like that
that's adding more weight but giving you
a little bit more protection as well now
these are the 4 200 pound forks i want
to reiterate they are way too big for
this tractor we're just showing them on
here just so you can see what they're
all about these are for a large compact
or even a utility tractor as well these
are shown with this optional full brick
guard that's what this kind of squared
checkered thing is called up here you
can get it with or without it's an extra
cost to get it with these are 60 inch
tines that we have on here too so that's
an option as well but a very strong very
rugged beefy
set of pallet forks that's never gonna
fail you and here's a quick look at the
5500 pound set this is without that full
brick guard on there so the 5500 and
4200 are pretty similar if you don't
want to get that full brick guard a good
look at it here now one thing you're not
going to see in this video are clamp on
forks for your bucket and i am just not
a big fan of those we we can sell them
but i just choose not to we get a lot of
folks that have had a set of those forks
and just are sick and tired of them and
end up getting a regular set of forks
like what you see here but clamp on
forks yes they are a lot cheaper all
right they're going to clamp onto your
bucket to the bottom edge of your bucket
and so they can oftentimes become loose
and wiggly and wobbly some of them do
have a cross brace section as well which
can can help but it's also going to push
your load point even further out because
they're they're clamping on to the front
edge that leading edge on your bucket so
it's pushing that point way out there
there's a likelihood of potentially
damaging your bucket or bending the
bottom rail of it as well
pallet forks i'm telling you they're one
of the handiest attachments that you can
get for your tractor we sell them all
the time and it's just amazing we talked
about the uses for them but you're
constantly finding ways to use pallet
forks even putting your attachments on
individual pallets then you can shuffle
them around and organize as needed it's
just such a handy attachment to have all
right so these are the fork extensions i
was talking about and we use these
things all the time and so
easy to put on they're pretty
lightweight but they can give you a lot
of extra length if you need it in a
pinch and you can take them right back
off store them pretty easy too but
we got these from palletforks.com so
i'll post a link to where you can get
them through there but they're super
easy to put on you can see that that
steel loop that's there you just kind of
tuck that underneath
so it's kind of around the whole
time
slide it back and you might have a
little
play right you can use them with wider
forks as well but these come in super
handy they're pretty cheap i'm sure
they've gone up in price because
everything does since
since we bought them but overall if
you're kind of kicking yourself because
you wish you would have got longer tines
originally up front from wherever you
got your forks this could be a cheaper
way to get a longer set when you need
them in a pinch all right so that's a
lot of information to throw you there
hopefully you found that helpful
again for me i i wouldn't lose a whole
lot of sleep about the the tine length
and jdqa is for john deere quick attach
ssqa for skid steer quick attach you
know you can even use these two thousand
pound rated forks on a kubota tractor
like this one right here you could go up
to the 4200 pound you're not gonna see
you're not going to realize that benefit
for the most part though but if you just
really kind of if you're rough on things
maybe you want to step it up one notch
and go to the 4200 pounds otherwise this
set right here is our standard duty set
that we sell for anything like your your
john deere 3e tractors the 3r the 4
series and then again to the 5 series as
well on your kubota's it's going to be
like the standard l series the grand l
series and then the m series like what
you see here and again the ultralights
these are where it's at for you small
tractor owners and we sell an absolute
boatload of these forks ship them all
across the country the one thing we get
asked a decent amount is can you get
them with a receiver that's that's built
in you that's welded in here somewhere
and hla does not offer that right now
now i prefer to hook up trailers to the
back side of my tractor so if you're
looking at the ballast way we talked
about the safety our versa bracket has a
built-in two inch receiver okay so the
versa bracket
is versatile okay it holds suitcase
weights for your ballast weight it's got
chain grab hooks on there it's got a
chainsaw holder it's got the two inch
receiver it's quick hitch compatible or
hook up right to your three-point hitch
so make sure you're setting yourself up
right out of the gate alrighty folks
that's gonna wrap it for us today
hopefully you found this guide helpful
if you are looking for a set of forks
maybe some ballast weight anything else
for your tractor we're happy to help
check out goodworkstractors.com we sell
and ship all over the country if you
enjoyed today's video we'd love to have
you tag along hit that subscribe button
right down below i want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to stop by
and until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Applause]